what is this Rome I know probably this
is how they
started Whitney Cummings who was on Joe
Rogan and she said this about what's
happening to the animals now of
California like a raccoon and so I call
Animal Control this is like the most
California response I'm like I have this
raccoon in my tree and she's like yeah
that's where they live I'm like yeah no
this this where I live get the
it's sick something's wrong with it last
thing I need is aing coyote eating it
and then we have rabid coyotes I I have
to deal with that and she goes well a
lot of the wild animals in California
are acting really weird right now
because people are testing their cocaine
for Fentanyl and if it tests positive
they flush it down the toilet so they're
spent all in the water so the coyotes
and raccoons are acting really weird
what that's what she said yes I was like
if you're telling me there's fentanyl
coyotes I got to get the out of here but
how wait a minute what about people did
people get that water how was that
where's that water going I mean they
already probably where's like does that
mean that waste water from a toilet
flushing goes out into the streets what
is this Rome I know probably this is how
they start the same uh fate at okay I
can't speak to the veracity and absolute
truthiness of the claim but I have no
doubt that Media Matters will be
factchecking me on this um but the let's
just say it's ballpark sort of right
that this is what now is happening and
there will be coyotes on fenel killing
the California liberals who will be
going I think Hitler did that
that's where we're
at